[Applause]
yes yes yes yes yes yes
oh my God
psychotic people here oh get them all
out of here they're scaring me
happy Thursday everyone well as happy as
one can be in NYC hit it Frankie
only in New York
Start Spreading the News
we're all gonna die
[Applause]
so funny it is
pretty good that was Gene all right so
yesterday a grand jury indicted Daniel
penny in Jordan Neely's accidental death
you know the story pennies the Marine
who stepped in when nearly a deranged
homeless felon was threatening
passengers on the subway
so thanks to Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg
who chose to charge Penny this heroic
Marine may go to jail for doing what he
thought was right that sucks
so what's this mean for all of us should
this affect the way you defend yourself
in a tense situation especially in New
York or other liberal cities or when
you're around cat yeah
if cities cannot guarantee your safety
then it's placed on your imperfect
imperfect shoulders
that's a funny word to screw up
perhaps it's time to sue these
politicians who put us in this situation
forcing people like Penny to defend
others against Mad Men set free by these
very same politicians
for now we realize there's a price to
pay for being a hero but absolutely none
for being a villain and that's because
the left has politicized safety which
means whomever you consider a risk to
you and others is now a protected class
and therefore your suspicion can only be
racist so just give in to the perp
because fighting him well that would be
plain bigotry you're the villain now
which is amazing since it's so hard to
tell who the bad guys are anymore like
that knife fight I always say that just
like that knife fight uh in the middle
of a New York City street last week two
guys start fist fighting in the
crosswalk one pulls out a knife fatally
stabs the other guy to death a few
people tried to stop it but they didn't
want to get stabbed either and everybody
else just walked on by you can see Jamie
list out go right by there
you can hardly blame them though why get
involved right they learn their lesson
just wait for the cops to show up and
draw a Chalk Outline on the ground sadly
New York City has used up so much chalk
there's none left for the school
teachers
those diagrams always look like they're
dancing
was wanted for murder in Baltimore it's
true the streets of NYC are so bad even
the murderers aren't safe
Tuesday another man was stabbed to death
on a train after arguing with a young
couple and punching the woman in the
face
again the stabbing victim who punched
the woman in the face was an ex-con the
boyfriend of course charged with
manslaughter
but at least we arrested Donald Trump
huh your documents are safe now no paper
cuts
a woman in Manhattan was paralyzed last
month when a man shoved her head in
front of a moving train
but the mayor's going to make sure that
guy's punished by spending a few months
in prison eating vegan food
another young woman in Queens was pushed
under the tracks last week but was able
to get to safety she actually went to
her prom that night which means she's
already gone to more proms than Jamie
laughs
crime is so rampant in New York City
Bill de Blasio feels safe finally
admitting that he murdered that
groundhog you remember that remember
that huh
quote this is what he says why would you
want an elected official to hold a
groundhog I don't know anything about
holding groundhogs well dude you didn't
know anything about running a major city
and it didn't it didn't stop you from
killing that too
that groundhog
yeah thank you that groundhog got off
easy
his death was quick
so why is this happening well because
Democrats allow it to happen they look
the other way they reduce sentences for
violent crime they release Predators
they demonize the police they eliminate
bail and then they call it criminal
justice reforms but the only people who
love the reforms are the criminals
themselves their lives have never been
better
and if you ask them they'll say business
is booming because it is and for the
rest of us life becomes a trap where the
environment that left fostered allows
for Dangerous scenarios that Force good
people to try to do the right thing and
get arrested
or don't do the right thing and die
so my solution why not give us citizens
a heads up
if you CR if you give creeps Freedom
that at least give us a running start
when a criminal psycho enters a Subway
our phones should be beeping you know
like an amber alert perhaps prompted by
the perps ankle bracelet is that a
violation of his right to privacy
well you've already violated our right
to live
so go yourself
so
sorry Ralph fact is some of us are lucky
enough never to be in a situation where
we must choose between saving lives and
a manslaughter charge but if that ever
happens we hope someone like Mr penny
might be there to help but if Alvin
Bragg has his way no such luck you're on
your own
hope God forgives him for being here
tonight founder and chairman of the
faith and freedom Coalition robbery
for Father's Day his kids are giving him
a paternity test actor writer and
comedian Jamie lisow
she's Saucy bossy and thinned like
Dental flossie
Fox News contributor captive
and his arms are so big his sleeves are
miserable my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyra
Jamie that's a very serious monologue
and as a comedian you're often
challenged to come up with something
light or humorous when topics like this
arise I assume you will fail at that
thank you
yeah I'll be honest with you when I when
I saw this I was like yes I can finally
use all those sad murder jokes that have
been piling up
but there is some serious stuff man the
Marine steps in he's a hero and this
sets a terrible precedence and um I'll
tell you what I did find out from the
story that I do not know how to spell
precedent
I do not know I swear I was typing in my
computer to take like notes and I wrote
terrible press it and I was like I'm
gonna make a point tonight and then it
kept changing into president terrible
and I was like well that makes sense too
yes um you do have a terrible you ever
spell a word so wrong your computer's
like I don't even have any suggestions
yes I can't help you you're right it
gave me one suggestion it said read a
book dummy
but so many like so many weird stuff
like the um those two guys knife
fighting in the crosswalk I appreciate
them being safety conscious and fighting
in the crossword
did you see on the sign it was two
little white figures fighting in the
crosswalk
and you're watching the people just get
what there was a nurse yeah a nurse
walking through the crosswalk and she
goes around them and it's just like it's
insane because two stories freaking out
the woman was like there was a lady
pushing a three-year-old baby she was
yeah that was the one story a few more
details she was pushing the baby she was
yelling at the baby yeah so then the
woman who stabbed her she stabbed her
because she was mad that she was yelling
at her baby which I don't know a ton
about this but I would guess the least
effective way to stop someone from
screaming is to stab them yes
uh Dr Jill Biden agrees and she is a
doctor yeah and just and what and one
one last thing like that one story that
freaked me out because I get scared
about this stuff is like though there
was the one story where the um guy
punches this woman right and then her
boyfriend stabs the guy and I'm just
mortified of like a girl I'm dating
starting a fight yeah you know because
you have to step it yeah that's always a
problem oh my God and this guy stepped
in like step I would do something like
way more subtle you know just like like
pretend that I didn't see it yes
oh
that's what I do all right Ralph welcome
to the show first time on thank you
excellent thank you very much
with this ruling or this uh case affect
the way you might defend yourself in a
tense situation like the way what Jamie
says if you if you know that you do the
right thing you'll still go to jail
uh probably even before this I I would
have been careful to you know to use
Force unless I had to for pretty obvious
reasons I'm not sure that I'm gonna get
treated you know
uh equally under the law your hands
aren't lethal weapons in in these major
cities but you know Greg seriously it is
a it is a reminder
that elections have consequences and
that policy matters yeah people lose
their lives I mean when Rudy Giuliani
became mayor of this city
this city was violent out of control and
was viewed as unmanageable and through a
combination of community policing
the broken windows approach to Crime
Control the idea that small crimes lead
to bigger crimes and non-violent crime
leads to violent crime right
uh he termed Times Square into
Disneyland
this city became the safest major city
in the world
and through
you know
and Mike Bloomberg continued those
policies and under de Blasio and now
Eric Adams the city is unraveling but
what's really scary Greg to me I live in
Atlanta this is happening in every major
city in America
I live probably
a mile from two of the biggest malls in
the southeastern United States where a
seven-year-old child was shot to death
by a stray bullet sitting in a parking
lot in a mall
uh when you go to these malls there are
cops everywhere
with M16s yeah and it's really very
simple
we know who the criminals are we know
who's responsible for this violence
they're being released on no
recognizance bonds
we've got prosecutors like Bragg who
won't prosecute him
while he's chasing Donald Trump down
and uh it's a very serious problem and I
think what we need is we need a change
of leadership in New York City and a lot
of other cities all across America
Pirates
do you think it do you think it's too
late do you think the cities just
screwed
well I think New York always can say
well at least it's not San Francisco
so you know they got that going yeah
it's always it could be worse you know
but um
obviously this is a thousand percent uh
trial by being white if he was any other
color unfortunately he wouldn't be he
would have been it never would have got
this far what that's yeah there's one
white guy going yeah about time
see how scared you are yeah
my homies look like yeah I mean clap for
yourself damn
trying to help you out even Jamie was
like please clap for me
even though uh again you don't nobody
you don't see anybody die
but he was it was two minutes that he
had this guy down not stretched to 15
like we're seeing exaggerated and the
people helping him were people of color
the people afraid were women and people
of color still didn't matter because the
narrative says he's white it had to be
racist like he got up in the morning and
he was just looking for one and he just
hit the lottery in a Subway yeah you
know uh I have put guys out with that
same hole in bodyguarding and bouncing
clubs and keeping people safe
I still would not hesitate to do the
same thing in that situation but the
average American
you can't do it yeah if you're white you
got to stop investigating all the all
the stuff you see in horror movies white
people don't do anymore yeah
in the Attic
[Laughter]
all right you see a burning building go
well I'm sure somebody's got it
protect yourself because this man's life
is going to be forever changed even with
acquittal he'll be stained yeah uh you
know and so that's the ugly side of it
but this has nothing to do with race and
everything to do with uh men we're
missing in this country and one man
stepped up and this is what happens yeah
you know Kat uh are you going to be less
likely to intervene in violent
situations because
you throw a pretty mean right cross
good
[Laughter]
I'm not up on my punching terminology
well I mean unfortunately I mean this
similar thing happened to a black guy
Jordan Williams who stabbed a guy who
was on the train saying he's going to
erase somebody and then punch the guy's
girlfriend right uh and you know he was
arrested if somebody punched me I would
not want everyone around and be like gee
hope he doesn't do it again
there should be I mean you have to
understand that in situations like this
too I'm sure they're very scary
um when you feel like maybe your life
hangs in the balance of the life of
somebody you care about hangs in the
balance and you might not be thinking
okay well what is the exact appropriate
amount of force to use and should I do
this or should I do that I mean these
are really scary situations and I I do
not think I would succeed in one as you
pointed out
um and I think sadly
I think people are really too focused on
okay does this fit the right narrative
is this going to push a narrative for me
or if it doesn't based on race or
whatever else and not the fact that
these are people's lives and New York is
where a lot of people myself included
live and I think people should start
focusing on wanting the right thing to
happen regardless of what it does for
your narrative yeah excellent points hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else